[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et à tous Bienvenue
c'est sens public votre rendez-vous
quotidien de débat de chronique et de
reportage sur Public Sénat deux thèmes
seulement en 90 minutes pour prendre le
temps de donner du sens à l'actualité
grâce à nos experts et voici le sommaire
de ce 23 janvier une agricultrice de 37
ans tuée sur un barrage en Arriège des
chauffeurs routiers qui joignent leur
camions au tracteur sur l'autoroute A7
le mouvement de colère des agriculteurs
français semble pas prêt de s'éteindre
que peut faire le gouvernement face à
des revendications protéiformes le
virage écologique rendu nécessaire par
l'urgence climatique est-il trop rapide
le rassemblement national va-t-il
profiter de cette grogne pour progresser
encore avant les élections européennes
on en débat dans une minute et puis pour
notre second thème volontairement décalé
de l'actualité du jour gros plan sur les
sans abris en France parmi eux de plus
en plus d'enfants on estime que chaque
soir il y a 2800 enfants qui sont
refoulés par le 115 ça veut dire que
c'est des enfants dont les parents ont
appelé le 115 pour avoir un hébergement
d'urgence pour la nuit même et que le
115 leur a dit désolé on a plus de place
donc c'est des enfants qui vont passer
la nuit dehors dans une voiture sous une
tente dans des conditions très
difficiles depuis Lionel juspin en 2002
tous les premier ministres ou président
de la République ont annoncé le zéro
sans abri sans jamais tenir cette
promesse est-elle illusoire la prise en
charge des en domicile fixe est-elle
enfin intégrée à la politique du
logement ne ratez pas les explications
et la confrontation de nos experts sur
ce thème ce sera dans 3ois quarts
d'heure mais d'abord donc le drame de la
nationale 20 dans l'Ariège et la
mobilisation des agriculteurs avec
Mathias
Arz la mobilisation des agriculteurs est
en deuil ce mardi matin une manifestante
présente sur un point de blocage àamier
dans l'Ariège a été fauché avec sa
famille par une voiture donc on est
certain que la voiture qui s'est engagée
sur de fois de voix qui est arrivé à à
pleine vitesse sur le le Ballau de foin
elle s'était à un moment à quelques
kilomètres de là elle avait contourner
un dispositif visant à interdire l'accès
à cette deux fois de voie dispositif
très bien matérialisé il fallait
vraiment vouloir essayer de se frayer un
chemin à travers la mère de 37 ans est
décédée sur le coup son mari et sa fille
de 14 ans se trouvent toujours dans un
état grave un drame qui a provoqué les
mois jusqu'au plus haut sommet de l'État
le drame de Pamier nous bouleverse tous
je pense avec émotion aux victimes et à
leurs proches uillers présent sur le
plateau d'une chaîne d'information au
moment de l'annonce du drame Arnaud
Rousseau président de la FNSE a réagi
dans le moment où le monde agricole fait
entendre sa colère et où nous attendons
des décisions urgente j'invite
évidemment l'ensemble des agriculteurs à
être vigilant sur les conditions de
sécurité parce que faire passer nos
messages c'est aussi assurer la sécurité
de chacun euh et ça veut dire aussi que
le premier ministre doit aller vite
maintenant pour nous apporter des
réponses très concrètes hier soir les
principales organisations syndicales
étaient reçues à Matignon si pour
l'heure aucun accord n'a abouti le
Premier ministre Gabriel Atal a voulu
envoyer un message aux agriculteurs
présents ce mardi devant les préfectures
nous regarderons toutes les propositions
et nous prendrons toutes les mesures
utiles et nécessaires dans le cadre du
projet de loi porté par le ministre de
l'Agriculture oui nous allons avancer
sans tabou sans faux semblant avec une
détermination et avec la mobilisation de
cette majorité qui elle n'a jamais fait
défaut à nos agricul
plus tôt dans la journée le président de
la République Emmanuel Macron sommet son
gouvernement d'être pleinement mobilisé
pour apporter des solution concrètes aux
difficultés rencontrées par les paysans
le deuil et la colère des agriculteurs
français on en débat tout de suite avec
Sophie prima bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
sénatrice LRD ziveline vice-présidente
du Sénat et ingénieur agronome de de
formation Thierry pouche bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes économiste chef du
service études économiques et prospectiv
aux Chambre d'Agriculture France et
chercheurs associé au laboratoire regard
de l'université reince champagne
hardarden gér Guibert bonsoir bienvenue
à vous fondateur président de la
Fabrique écologique et auteur du grand
malentendu climatique livre paru aux
Éditions de l'Aube on est également en
duplexe avec Rémi Duma qui est
viticulteur dans l'héro bonsoir vous
êtes vice-président des jeunes
agriculteurs Bienvenue à vous et ilisski
bonsoir Émilie bienvenue spécialiste en
communication politique et éditorialiste
pour sens public euh Sophie prima une
question très très générale cette colère
des agriculteurs
elle ne vous surprend pas pourquoi non
elle ne nous surprend pas ici au Sénat
parce que dans les territoires où nous
sommes implantés l'ensemble de nos
collègues assis d'ailleurs sur tous les
bancs du Sénat sentait cette colère
proteformme a dit votre journaliste dans
dans dans son dans son introduction mais
c'est exactement ça c'est-à-dire chaque
métier chaque région a aujourd'hui des
raisons d'être inquiet des raisons de
voir son revenu diminuer des raisons
d'être inquiet des décisions qui sont
prises à droite à gauche et en réalité
on sentait bien que tout ça était en
train de de cou il y avait ce mouvement
des panneaux de de signalisation
d'entrée des villes qui étaient retourné
ça a été sous-estimé ça je pense que ça
a été sous-estimé mais ça vient de bien
plus loin que ça je veux dire on entend
quand même dans nos campagnes depuis
très longtemps le problème du revenu
d'ailleurs qui a donné lieu aux états
généraux de l'alimentation puis à égalim
1 égalim 2 égalim 3 voyez on a ce
problème du revenu on a le problème de
la transmission entre générations qui
faisait l'objet du du du projet de loi
qui était proposé par le gouvernement
qui vient d'être retiré pour être abondé
visiblement euh on a le problème des
norme on a le problème des contrôles on
a le problème de l'eau on a le problème
des bassines voyez
ça c'est un truc protéiforme qui est
différents régions par région j'allais
dire métier par métier de l'agriculture
mais qui aujourd'hui sur un un déclic
est en train de se répandre partout Tiry
pouche à quel point les les agriculteurs
français je comprends bien que voilà
c'est c'est c'est comme comme on l'a dit
très varié en fonction des régions et
des et des des métiers à quel point
subissent-il une forme de déclassement
aujourd'hui alors cette notion de
déclassement elle est également
protéiforme parce que c'est un
déclassement économique on a quand même
parlé depuis 15 ans maintenant de
l'érosion de la compétitivité de
l'agriculture française au Sénat il y a
eu plusieur rapport sur ce thème euh
donc là il y a déjà une prise de
conscience alors ça ne veut pas dire que
nous sommes complètement déclassés sur
le commerce extérieur nous sommes encore
un état-membre excédentaire ce qui n'est
pas le cas de tous les autres
États-membres mais sur C déclassement
par interrompre moi en tête je je je
pense revenu là c'est c'est plus ça ma
question si je suis plus précis alors
voilà sur le revenu c'est quand même
quelque chose qui s'inscrit sur une
période assez longue euh notamment au
gré des réformes de la politique
agricole commune puisque il y a eu un
une redéfinition des aides elles ont été
même orientées parfois à la baisse le
budget n'a pas forcément beaucoup
augmenté sur le l'agriculture donc il y
a une lame de fond et les deux dernières
années c'est-à-dire enfin 2021 et 2022
on a l'impression qu'il y avait eu un
voile puisque il y avait eu une très
forte augmentation du revenu des
agriculteurs en moyenne nationale
évidemment et on avait l'impression que
à la faveur évidemment de la guerre en
Ukraine de la flambée des prix on est
éit un petit peu sorti d'affaire et que
ça allait être une tendance qui allait
s'inscrire dans la durée en 2023 c'est
la rechute puisque les prix se sont
orienté à la baisse et que les charges
aussi mais un rythme beaucoup moins
soutenu mais en plus à la fin de l'année
2023 sur les de TR derniers mois les
charges se sont même mis à
augmenter il y a un effet ciseau qu'on
craignait mais qui est en train de se
réaliser ouais gér giibert c'est c'est
une question par que je j'entends le
lien et il est évident entre politique
agricole commune subvention et revenus
des des agriculteurs c'est une question
d'argent de moyens ou c'est aussi un
manque de de cap de de vision pour vous
moi je crois que d'abord vous avez tout
à fait raison de le signaler c'est
d'abord une question économique et avec
une agriculture en effet qui est très
différente selon les endroits mais
globalement c'est une question
économique une question de revenu et
c'est vrai que il y a eu cet épisode des
deux dernières années qui a fait croire
que les revenus augmentaient beaucoup et
donc il y a d'autant plus évidemment une
une déception même une grande difficulté
parce que quand vous avez vos revenus
qui augmentent pendant 2 ans puis
ensuite qui qui qui chute assez
fortement c'est c'est un c'est un vrai
sujet il y a un deuxième sujet c'est que
et donc c'est ça l'essentiel on va venir
évidemment sur les questions écologiques
mais je pense que c'est la première
chose et la chose essentielle ensuite
l'agriculture est dans une situation
très particulière puisque l'agriculture
est à la fois
responsable du climat puisqu'elle émet
20 % des gaz à effet de serre elle est
en même temps victime du climat puisque
les agriculteurs souffr beaucoup un
certain nombre d'entre eux en tout cas à
la fois des épisodes extrêmes de de la
conséquence sur la variabilité des prix
et cetera et cetera et en même temps
c'est la solution une des
solutions on est forcément c'est vrai
que c'est vrai que sur la place des
agriculteurs dans la société on ne sent
pas aujourd'hui de messages clair sur
qu'est-ce que l'agriculture en 2050 au
niveau français ou au niveau européen
européen il y a un Pact vert enfin on a
le sentiment après on va on va en
reparler on va peut-être le critiquer
mais on a le sentiment juste a un je
pense que les deux les deux niveaux sont
de ce point de vue là c'est-à-dire que
au niveau français il est clair quand on
parle du climat par exemple on parle
jamais d'agriculture vous avez remarqué
c'est quand même quelque chose d'assez
incroyable et au niveau européen disons
que le lien qui est d'ailleurs assez
ténu entre la politique agricole commune
et les questions climatiques est très
faible et il y a pas eu de véritable
message donné on pourra y revenir sur un
certain nombre de sujets et donc je
pense que cet cet élément explique que
les agriculteurs en fait ne savent plus
où ils vont ouaque de cap je vous donne
la parole dans un instant Émilie mais je
voudrais entendre iduma là-dessus on on
va détailler les les les différentes
revendications là là où le bablesse en
quelque sorte mais sur ce cette vision
d'avenir est-ce est-ce que pardon je
vais trop vite c'est ce qui vous manque
aujourd'hui Rémi Luma ah ben clairement
clairement ça fait plusieurs années que
l'on demande aussi cette vision d'avenir
là sur l'agriculture française et
européenne en général aujourd'hui on
enfin ça a été dit à l'instant
c'est-à-dire que sur le climat sur
l'environnement l'agriculture est au
rendez-vous partout euh soit critiqué
soit
idolâtré mais en attendant il y a
plusieurs défis le premier défi quand
même c'est la souveraineté alimentaire
il faut pas le perdre de vue
l'agriculture est fait pour produire de
l'alimentation en premier on va être de
plus en plus sur la planète donc il va
falloir quand même produire de
l'alimentation en second c'est
l'écologie on est les premiers
écologistes parce que la terre c'est
notre outil de travail donc bien sûr
qu'on ne va pas la détruire parce qu'on
a envie de travailler avec on a envie de
la transmettre à nos générations futures
euh donc on est là aussi au rendez-vous
en fait là où on a du mal à se placer
c'est effectivement dans les politiques
publ euh où on nous pousse à être plus
vertueux pour sauver la planète euh
sachant qu'il y a des mesures qui sont
faites mais les moyens que l'on nous
donne à côté en alternative ne sont pas
forcément mieux quand on grate un petit
peu plus loin pour la planète sauf que
souvent c'est voilà on regarde ça de
loin on a trop tendance de parler
agriculture sans les principaux
intéressés c'est-à-dire nous les
agriculteurs qui vivons au quotidien les
les alléas climatiques mais aussi les
solutions que l'on peut apporter quand
on enlève la molécule par exemple j'aime
pas trop en parler mais c'est quand même
symbolique le glyphosate on va à la
place faire du Labour donc au niveau du
carbone on va moins capter de carbone on
va passer plus de de temps en tracteur
donc rejeter plus de gaz à effet de
serre à travers notre consommation de
carburant donc vous voyez c'est tous ces
équilibres là apportter et et la France
aujourd'hui et l'Europe n'a pas une
vision claire parce qu'on nous parle
tous les jours de souverineté
alimentaire en France mais en même temps
on nous met des normes environnementales
qui nous empêche de faire cette
souveraineté alimentaire on vous donne
pas les moyens finalement d'appliquer
cette politique c'est ce que je résume
et on vous entendra plusieurs fois
évidemment pendant pendant ce débat
vouliez intervenir oui parce que il y a
toutes ces transitions dont on parle
écologique souveraineté alimentaire mais
il y aussi a le modèle économique qui a
pas évolué ou en tout cas on n' pas eu
ce regard c'est plus les les fermes à
l'ancienne familiale ça existe de moins
en moins il y a des exploitants qui
essaient de se réunir collectivement
pour trouver des nouveaux formats et
vous voyez par exemple dans l'industrie
ou alors ailleurs dans d'autres secteurs
économique on parle des start-ups on
parle de tout ça mais dans l'agriculture
c'est comme si on les on les gardait un
petit peu à l'ancienne et on on n'arrive
pas à les aider cette loi était là
justement pour les aider pour installer
des nouveaux jeunes qui sont plus
forcément les mêmes c'est pas forcément
des fils d'exploitants ou des filles
d'exploitants qui reprennent la ferme
c'est des néo ruraux qui vont essayer de
se débrouiller avec des modèles
différents qui ont des envies et
localement il y a des envies aussi
d'acheter proche et tout ça on n pas on
n' pas su dépoussiérer ça ou en tout cas
regardeer un peu retirer la poussière
parce que ça bouge beaucoup même en
terme d'innovation il y a énormément de
choses qui se passent et on n pas ce
regard là comme si on gardait ce secteur
un peu à l'ancienne alors que ça bouge
énormément et qu'on devrait don
comme il y a énormément de variété c'est
pas forcément vrai pour tous les
agriculteurs et pour t tout il y a des
nouveaux modèles qui qui sont là mais
alors je voudrais il y a plein de thèmes
à aborder et on va commencer par un un
focus tout de suite sur la la question
finalement du virage écologique et et
sur les normes environnementales qui
selon les agriculteurs se s'empilent les
unes au-dessus des autres écoutons le
vice-président de la FDSEA de loise il
blogue avec ses collègues l'autoroute
euh à 16 à hauteur de
Bovet on est en train de perdre notre
agriculture et nos agriculteurs nous
sommes en plein de plein de
problématiques et et que aujourd'hui ben
il faut se pencher voyez on nous autre
exemple on nous retire nous en France on
a une spécificité c'est qu'on nous
retire les produits phytosanitaires qui
sont pas retirés euh qui sont pas
retirés dans d'autres pays européen par
exemple la cerise aujourd'hui vous allez
plus avoir de cerise française pourquoi
parce que en Italie ils ont le droit
d'utiliser un produit qui tue certains
insectes qui vont détruire la cerise
chez nous c'est pas possible on veut
faire plus blanc que blanc et à force
d'être plus blanc que blanc
l'agriculture devient transparente le
sens de la formule la force de de de
vouloir faire plus blanc que blanc
l'agriculture devient transparente
Sophie prima on la vraie question
l'urgence écologique je P l'urgence
climatique on en est tous conscient
autour de cette table après c'est la la
la la question du rythme est-ce que
est-ce que ce virage alors qu'on peut
symboliser par le PACT vert en étant un
peu simplificateur au niveau européen
mais il y a aussi une volonté au niveau
français est-ce qu'il est tout
simplement trop rapide insupportable
pour les agriculteurs ou pas
suffisamment accompagné pour les
agriculteurs d'abord je voudrais dire
quelque chose c'est que le modèle
agricole est en train d'évoluer il est
en train d'évoluer parce qu'il y a des
nouvelles générations qui arrive et
parce que les anciennes générations
comprennent les enjeux climatiques et
les enjeux environnementaux et donc
c'est pas du tout ça qui est combattu ce
qui est combattu c'est les normes sur
les normes qui parfois sont
contradictoires les unes aux autres et
qui sont dans un étau que les
agriculteurs ne savent plus les
appliquer et parfois ils les appliquent
mais ils sont sanctionnés par par l'État
territorial qui vient les sanctionner je
prends un exemple pour qui est assez
emblématique on veut replanter des ha
les ha c'est important ça crée la
biodiversité ça ça empêche d'utiliser
des produits phyos enfin bon il y a
plein de bénéfices auis qu'on a enlevé
il y a quelques années il y a 12
réglementations dans des codes
différents qui régissent la la
plantation l'entretien des ha mais en
fait aujourd'hui les agriculteurs il
disent je vais surtout pas planter une
parce que je vais avoir 12
règlementations et je ne saurai pas et à
un moment ou un autre je me ferai
rattraper par la police et donc en fait
c'est on pourrait multiplier les
exemples comme celu on peut multiplier
les exemples vous avez en ce moment il y
a eu certains journalistes qui
relaissent cette information mais qui
est vrai euh des des directions
départementales qui sont en train de
demander aux agriculteurs qui sont
inondés dans le nord de la France de
prouver qu'ils avaient qu'ils avaient
planté des couverts entre les deux ils
ont un m 50 d'eau dans leur champ ENF ça
ça n'a pas de sens vous voyez c'est ça
en fait que les agriculteur ne supporte
plus c'est d'être la cible d'être montré
du doigt comme étant réfractaire aux
nouvelles méthodes de parfois ne pas
avoir les moyens de gérer cette
transition parce qu'il faut de
l'investissement il faut une ouverture à
l'innovation et se retrouver dans des
impasses qui sont des impasses pour eux
assez dramatique alors votre avis
là-dessus à tous les deux je commence
avec vous tiierry pouche est-ce que
c'est une question de de vision d'avenir
ou de cap qui a été donné en matière de
transition environnementale qui est pas
le bon ou est-ce que c'est simplement on
a le bon cap mais on voilà on est on est
victime de de notre obésité
administrative française et européenne
sur le pacte vert il y a quand même une
précision à apporter il a été publié en
2019 sauf qu'entreetemps le contexte
international a changé bien sûr et que
cette guerre en Ukraine qu'on le veuille
ou non bouleverse depuis le début les
équilibres alimentaires mondiaux et que
par voie de conséquence l'Union
européenne a peut-être tout intérêt dans
la dans la situation actuelle
d'envisager éventuellement de réexaminer
le texte en intégrant le contexte
international parce que toutes les
études d'impact qui ont été réalisés sur
ce pacte vert ont bien montré des
États-Unis à la Hollande en passant par
l'Allemagne y compris l'étude de la
Commission elle-même que il y aurait un
décrochage des productions donc on va
moins produire en Europe avec le pacte
vert prod et si on veut maintenir les
capacités d'approvisionnement il va
falloir recourir à l'importation ce que
montrre ces études d'impact et on
revient sur la question de souveraineté
alimentaire don par
souveré un instant donc il y a des
contradictions qu'il va falloir examiner
et évidemment lever est-ce qu'on doit
choisir jérud giilbert entre
souveraineté alimentaire européenne et
virage écologique non je P moi je pense
pas du tout je pense que si vous voulez
quand on dit l'accumulation des normes
al il y a certainement du toilettage à
faire sur un certain nombre de sujets
bon mais au-delà de ça je pense que les
deux vrais sujets sont les suivants
l'accompagnement c'est-à-dire que vous
pouvez pas demander à quelqu'un en effet
de moins u du gphos ce qui demande du
travail en plus pour l'agriculteur si
par ailleurs vous le rémunérez pas à la
hauteur de ce travail bon c'est c'est
très simple à comprendre mais je crois
pas que c'est c'est encore infusé au
niveau des de la décision bon ça c'est
le premier point et deuxième point c'est
vrai que le virage écologique exige un
certain nombre de règles mais moi je
pense qu'il faut sortir par le haut de
ce sujet et je pense qu'il faut avoir un
corpus de règles qui soit assez clair et
assez limité et et moi je suis partisan
à partir de là par exemple d'un d'un
d'un revenu garanti agroécologique et
qui permet aux agriculteurs non pas de
de de d'avoir d'avoir une rémunération
totale mais qui permet d'avoir un socle
garanti mieux payer ceux qui prennent le
virage jeisieuxay mais sur la base sur
la base d'un socle et sur lequel il ils
a pas pour chaque norme à déposer un
dossier à et cetera et cetera et cetera
donc une une simplification assez
radicale de de du sujet et je pense
qu'il faut sortir par le haut de ce
sujet je pense que ça serait très
mauvais pour les agriculteurs eumê euh
de se dire on va alléger les normes
environnementales parce que c'est
l'avenir les la transition
environnementale et que vous pouvez
faire ça à un moment donné mais 5 ans
après vous risquez d'être rattrapé par
la patrouille par exemple sur les
cerises moi je pense que il faut
évidemment arriver à valoriser le fait
que les cerises en France ont une norme
plus plus plus plus
stricte que d'autres pays européens on
valorise pas mais non aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui n on valorise pas pas du
tout et donc voilà c'est cette logique
là qu'il faut introduire BR le pardon
expliquez ça à Bruno le dans son numéro
du avec Leclerc sur la l' désinflation
des des prix Lecler le président des des
centres Lecler de celui-là dont vous
parlez non non
mais je vous donne la parole tout de
suite mais mais il y a réi Duma qui
voulait réagir parce que là là on est je
voudrais vraiment que vous nous
racontiez ce que vous vous avez fait
parce qu'on parle de virage écologique
et de rémunération c'est vous êtes
viticulteur le rappelle et et je crois
que vos produits sont je sais plus quel
est le terme haute valeur
environnementale et et vous ça ça a dû
vous demander de l'investissement je je
l'imagine est-ce que vous êtes mieux
payé pour autant et non
malheureusement c'est ce qu'on explique
aussi ce que aujourd'hui on a fait les
démarches pour être plus vertueux pour
adapter nos pratiques effectivement on
réduit nos produits phytosanitaires on
réduit on réduit nos herbicides euh tout
ça ça un coûte mine de rien euh même si
on réduit les produits il faut passer
ben mécaniquement notamment pour
l'herbicide du coup c'est plus de
passage de tracteur donc d'heure de
travail c'est plus de gasoil qui coûte
plus cher et en plus on nous enlève
l'exonération et tout ça en pilé la
fiscalité qui augmente comme tout le
monde le l'inflation on l'a subi pareil
le matériel qui a pris énormément de
pourcentage en gros pour produire un
hectare de de de vigne ça a pris 20 %
depuis 2019 le prix du vin payé à
l'heure aujourd'hui en haute valeur
environnementale est le même que mon
père touché il y a 20 ans euh donc elle
est où la normalité encore une fois on
demande pas le monde on demande juste de
payer le juste prix de nos produits
aujourd'hui on nous demande de la
qualité on nous demande d'être plus
performant environnementalement ça a un
prix il faut juste nous le payer euh si
c'est rémunérateur ça fera aussi venir
des jeunes d'un notre métier et ça a été
évoqué tout à l'heure il y a une loi euh
le projet de loi orientation pour le
renouvellement des générations en
agriculture euh qui est très important
pour nous qu'on a travaillé depuis 2022
euh il y a beaucoup de propositions qui
sont issues de jeunes agriculteurs parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a besoin d'une vision
claire effectivement mais aussi des
moyens humains et financiers pour
l'installation pour les transmissions
des exploitations parce qu'aujourd'hui
c'est un grand frein et quand on sait
que dans allez 5 7 ans la moitié des
agriculteurs vont partir à la retraite
il va falloir transmettre ses
exploitations effectivement pas que au
fils aux filles de des exploitants mais
aussi tout un chacun qui vient dans la
famille des agriculteurs voilà et c'est
tout ça qui met des freins et
aujourd'hui quand on n pas de vision qu'
nous rajoute des normes sur les normes
et cetera et des fois il y a des normes
qui sortent on a pas le temps de les
mettre en place a des nouvelles oui vous
avez à peine intégré les précédentes qu'
en a une nouvelle qui arri je je je
reste sur la question de la rémunération
parce qu'il y a aussi un principe de
réalité tiierry pou qu'il faut
malheureusement rappeler c'est
qu'aujourd'hui la demande de
bio elle est en train de plonger chez
les consommateurs c'est une autre forme
de contradiction avec le pacte vert qui
prévoit quand même l'augmentation des
surfaces dans l'Union européenne
consacrée à l'agriculture biologique et
depuis 2 ans encore une fois à la faveur
d'un contexte particulièrement difficile
bien les les consommateurs se sont
détournés des produits issus de
l'agriculture biologique en produits
laitiers en viticulture et aussi
évidemment en fruits et légumes parce
que il y a une question de prix c'est le
le le premier item qui intervient
lorsqu'on leur fait une enquête et
ensuite il y a même maintenant des des
considérations sur finalement la valeur
nutritive le lien entre le produit bio
et la santé et il se demande si un
produit àocé par exemple ou une autre un
autre signe on va on va jouer on va
miser sur le local plutôt que sur leà
donc voilà c'est encore une ça veut dire
qu'il y a des déconversions des
agriculteurs qui étaient passés au bio
qui on assiste à des retours au
conventionnel oui non c'est c'est
nombreux ça je sais pas si vous avez les
chiffres c'est pas une ça dépend des
filières non non c'est ça dépend des
filières on a des déjà quelques quelques
cas assez importants dans la filière
laitière évidemment av AFF à une épo
mais là encore on peut réfléchir sur
toute la le modèle économique de
l'agriculture c'est-à-dire tout ce qui
relève de l'offre mais il faut aussi ne
pas oublier que il y a un débouché
nécessaire pour absorber cette offre
c'est économiste qui vous parle voilà
donc c'est c'est c'est quand même
quelque chose d'important et ce qui se
passe en Allemagne est assez intéressant
de ce point de vue-l c'està-dire bien
c'estàd que évidemment il y a tout ce
qui relève de la fiscalité sur le gasoil
qu'on a mis en avant mais en regardant
de près l'Allemagne a fait le choix
d'une orientation de sa son agriculture
vers davantage d'environnement et de
transition
agroécologique sauf que le syndrome de
la dépendance de l'Allemagne au gaz
russe a touché l'alimentation maintenant
comme c'est le premier pays le plus gros
déficitaire de la balance commerciale
agroalimentaire l'Allemagne dégage un
déficit de 15 à 20 milliards par an il
se pose la question de leur sécurité
alimentaire et donc il y a une tension
maintenant entre les choix
environnementaux et la sécurité
alimentaire VO à quel point équation
elle est compliquée en France mais dans
les autres pays d'Europe on rappelle que
ce mouvement des agriculteurs il n'est
pas seulement français on vous avez
évoqué une proposition de loi qui a été
faite par les sénateurs on va en parler
tout de suite grâce à Quentin Calmet
parce que ça va vraiment nourrir notre
débat bonsoir Quentin bonsoir bienvenue
à vous les les sénateurs qui avaient
adopté l'an dernier donc une proposition
de loi pour un choc de compétitivité en
faveur de la ferme France c'est son nom
oui je parle sous votre contrôle Sophie
Prim parce que vous étiez la rapporteur
deex connaissez donc par cœur mais
effectivement l'année dernière Thomas la
droite et le centre au Sénat ont cherché
à alléger les contraintes qui pèsent sur
les agriculteurs la proposition de loi a
été adoptée en mai dernier à l'époque où
déjà le gouvernement parlait d'un texte
d'orientation d'avenir agricole donc qui
était prévu pour à l'époque l'été 2023
parmi les mesures du texte des sénateurs
il y a la création d'un Haut Commissaire
à la compétitivité agricole avec un plan
sur 5 ans un fond spécial pour
l'investissement et la recherche un
livret Agri pour flécher l'épargne des
Français sur le secteur agricole et
aussi créer du lien avec les concitoyens
et enfin des mesures fiscales comme des
crédits d'impôt des abattements et
exonération qui ét indexé sur
l'inflation alors on a parlé des des
normes le le texte il répond au
désarrois des agriculteurs sur ce thème
oui dans le texte le Sénat cherche
charge le Conseil d'État d'identifier
les cas de surtransposition c'est-à-dire
quand un texte de loi français et bien
chargé de décliner une directive
européenne se veut encore plus
contraignant c'est directement le
Conseil d'État qui serait à la manœuvre
donc texte qui avait été adopté ici au
Sénat en mai dernier est critiqué par la
gauche sénatoriale voilà notamment sur
les questions environnementales le texte
permet au ministre de culture de
s'opposé à une décision de laness
l'Agence nationale de sécurité sanitaire
par exemple lorsque l'agence décide de
retirer du marché un produit
phytosanitaire si' n'existe pas de
solution alternative efficiente le
ministre peut ainsi avoir le dernier mot
ça avait fait bondir les écologiste et
également sur l'eau un article du texte
consacre le caractère d'intérêt général
majeur des ouvrages de prélèvement de
stockage de l'eau agricole les bassines
doivent toutefois s'inscrire dans le
texte dans le respect d'un usage partagé
de l'eau mais cette mesure a été décrite
comme étant une provocation par les
écologistes après les tensions autour
des mégabassines le texte vous le disiez
Thomas a été adopté le 23 mai dernier
110 voix pour 94 contre au Sénat il
attend toujours d'être inscrit à l'ordre
du jour des députés à l'Assemblée
nationale mais pour l'heure il est
coincé dans la navette entre les deux
chambres du Parlement il faut dire aussi
que le gouvernement expliquait vouloir
reprendre certaines des mesures des
sénateurs dans son propre texte qu'on
attend pour a priori le premer semestre
2024 effectivement merci beaucoup
Quentin Sophie prima si ces
propositions étaient étai mis en œuvre
ça s ça changerait quoi pour le revenu
des agriculteurs est-ce que pour vous ça
aurait un un effet rapide et réel alors
l'idée c'est effectivement d'avoir des
des petites mesures en fait qui ont des
objectifs de compétitivité hyper rapide
vous avez mentionné des mesures fiscales
vous avez mentionné des mesures sur les
charges sociales il faut savoir par
exemple qu'à agriculture comparable les
charges sociales sur les agriculteurs
français sont 1,7 fois plus élevés que
chez nos collègues allemands par exemple
donc on a besoin d'aller chercher la
compétitivité vous voyez par exemple le
fameux bonus malus qui a été mis sur les
contrats courts dans le monde du travail
s'applique sur les saisonniers par
exemple dans l'agriculture c'est
hallucinant enfin voilà on doit sortir
ces charges sociales donc il y a à la
fois des mesures très pragmatiques il a
des mesures aussi un peu plus à long
terme notamment sur les capacités des
Français d'une façon générale à investir
auprès de leurs agriculteurs pour
moderniser transformer le modèle et
aller vers plus d'agroécologie on a
parlé aussi de de capter le le carbone
de les aider on a parlé de formation de
crédit de journée formation pour les
agriculteurs voilà donc dans la vie
quotidienne ça changerait à la fois des
données qui sont des données économiques
de base données fiscales donné de
charges sociales mais aussi une
perspective à plus long terme sur le
rôle de l'agriculture dans la transition
environnementale quand en parlé il est
dans les limbe un peu le le texte entre
entre le Sénat entre et l'Assemblée
nationale je laisse Quentin c'est moi
qui dit je vous laisse voilà donner le
nom qu'il vous plaît en tout cas il est
entre les deux chambres voilà ça c'est
sû est ent ça
n d'ailleurs mes de ou on ééis aujet de
de fin par exle l'amentation pour aller
vers le micro bénéfice agricole il a été
repris en compensation de du GNR dans le
projet de loi de de finan alors les
agriculteurs reçu par le Premier
ministre FNS hier d'autres organisations
ce mardi soir en attendant des mesures
concrètes il ne bouge pas comme ici sur
l'autoroute à 16 on est dans
l'Oise sera là le temps qu'il faudra on
a prévu tout ce qu'il fallait pour le
ravitaillement dormir on restera là sur
place plusieurs jours s'il le faut donc
le ministre le Premier ministre au
ministre de l'Agriculture nous donnerons
pas des actes concrets sur l'autoroute
A7 c'est l'une des informations de ce
mardi des des routiers on on joint leur
leur camion au tracteur Thierry pouche
est-ce que c'est un mouvement qui peut
faire Tach d'huile est-ce queine c'est
la grande crainte du gouvernement qui
surveille ça avec avec beaucoup
d'attention mais est-ce qu'il y a les
les ferments voilà d'un d'un d'un
mouvement qui se généraliserait d'après
vous bon je sais pas si je suis habilité
ni compétent pour répondre à cette
question
mais on est dans une situation oui
particulièrement complexe
tendue qui a pas l'hypothèse doit être
examiner avec avec soin ou remémy Duma
vous vouliez intervenir là-dessus est-ce
que vous voulez forcément que d'autres
professions vous rejoignent tiens euh
non déjà ce qui est sûr c'est que
l'ensemble des départements se mobilise
au fur à mesure de la semaine euh parce
que effectivement le la grogne arrive un
petit peu de partout et et dans chaque
secteur c'est problématique euh ensuite
c'est une manifestation agricole donc de
là ce que les autres nous rejoignent on
a peut-être pas les mêmes sujets de
manifestation donc restons sur nos
sujets agricoles et demain de
souveraineté alimentaire encore une fois
il faut que les Français comprennent que
oui on est désolé si on les bloque
quelques minutes mais peut-être que s'il
Mang demain euh c'est grâce à leur
patience quelques minutes derrière des
tracteurs Jér Guilbert depuis depuis 48h
là je lis beaucoup des gilets jaunes au
gilet vert est-ce que est-ce que ces
deux mouvements sont potentiellement
comparables
euh moi je pense que c'est l'intérêt des
agriculteurs que ça reste une
revendication agricole al les gilets
jaunes c'était quand même beaucoup plus
large ça concernait l'ensemble de la
population cela dit je pense qu'on ne
sort d'un mouvement comme ça que par une
initiative
forte d'écoute et et pas simplement de
cte avec les organisations syndicales
mais forte qui mett à
platement m des annonces il y a un
certain nombre de sujets sur lequel il
peut y avoir des annonces qui mettent à
plat les différents sujets avec me
semble-t-il la vraie la vraie direction
dans laquelle il faut aller c'est
l'accompagnement le changement dans
l'accompagnement des agriculteurs
vis-à-vis de la transition écologique je
on pourra prendre les exemples de du
gazol non routier les exemples des
bassines et cetera il y a il y a
vraiment une logique d'accompagnement
absolument essentielle
parce qu'un certain nombre de choix qui
pourrai être considérés comme
intelligents aujourd'hui seront
considérés dans 5 ans comme des choix
catastrophiques par exemple le choix de
telle ou telle bassine il faut pas être
contre le stockage de l'eau il il y a
tout à fait des des solutions
intelligentes de stockage de l'eau il
peut y avoir des choix en effet de
bassin qui sont très contreproductifes y
compris pour les agriculteurs donc il
faut en discuter il faut que les gens en
discutent oui mais ça c'est au cas par
cas c'est localement que ça mais
l'initiative de se dire et bien on
regarde ensemble rapidement les bassines
qui sont considéré comme la
nonappropriation par exemple par le
privé de l'eau qui est quand même un
sujet essentiel qui ne risque pas de
s'assécher contenu du réchauffement
climatique sujet qui se pose dans un
certain nombre de projets de bassine et
qui rend les bassines qui comme un non
sens bon et au contraire il y a d'autres
endroits il y a des stockages de l'eau
qui sont tout à fait rationnels tout à
fait intéressants donc ça il est pas il
est pas compliqué cas par cas de
regarder très vite ce qui est
intelligent et ce qui n'est pas sauf que
la complexité de la réponse
gouvernementale c'est qu'on attend une
réponse évidemment la plus générale
possible il y a des en jeu politique
évidemment à moins de 5 mois des
élections européennes
Émilie ce voilà ce conflit l'agriculture
donne aussi l'occasion de voir le de
plus près le le match si j'ose dire
entre Gabriel hatal et Jordan Bardella
mais oui quelque part on l'attendait ce
match depuis la nomination de Gabriel
hatal comme premier ministre comme si sa
présence lançait officiellement la
bataille du gouvernement contre le
rassemblement national en vue des
élections européenne du 9 juin le jeune
et doué àal étant semble-t-il l'un des
meilleurs adversaires du du camp
renaissance pour contrer le jeune et
doué Bardella et samedi les deux ont
redoublé d'effort chacun dans leur coin
et dans leur style pour se montrer
auprès au chevet des agriculteurs alors
vous avez regardé ça de près résultat
alors sur la forme le match à distance a
montré un un Atal très maconien
macronien en similie grand débat un peu
bavard un peu sérieux un peu austère un
Bardella qui était à l'inverse très
proche des agriculteur même physiquement
en discussion sur le fond on a eu des
promesses évidemment de la part d'atal
un premier ministre tout nouveau mais
qui est quand même l'héritier d'un bilan
de 7 ans qui est pas très porteur on se
souvient en 2017 Emmanuel Macron avait
déjà promis que les revenus des
agriculteurs allaient s'améliorer pas
sûr que les réponses avancé on l'a dit
le projet de loi qui est retardé parce
qu'il devrait être musclé en terme de
simplification est-ce que ça va pouvoir
calmer les ardeurs agricoles pour
l'instant par de fumée blanche de la
réunion d'hier entre le gouvernement et
la FNSEA et leors côté RN sur le fond
alors côté Bardella on est plutôt sur
des critiques évidemment de l'Europe de
Macron il y avait cette cette expression
une remise en question des normes
environnementales dont on parlait qui
plomb la production française alors que
les produits importés eux n'ont pas
besoin de les respecter mais les
réponses sont évidemment un peu
simplistes un projet de loi de
patriotisme économique qui donnerait par
exemple aux agriculteurs une priorité
aux cantines scolair la belle affaire
c'est un peu court et une exception
agriculturelle qui permettrait d'exclure
le secteur agricole des accords de libre
échange mais qui plomberaiit quand même
aussi les produits français notamment
haut de gamme vin et fromage donc des
visions quand même assez simplistes
allez on fait la on regarde les enjeux
les enjeux pour les deux ouais alors
pour le RN l'enjeu c'est pas forcément
le vote des agriculteurs puisque il
représente que 1,5 % de la population
active non ce qui les intéresse surtout
c'est cette France desoublié qu'il
représente et qui s'est aussi manifesté
durant la crise des gilets jaunes et qui
est de plus en plus attiré par les
sirènes de ce parti d'extrême droite
bardellaa pourrait aussi profiter du
tragique accident qui a eu lieu qui a
coûté la vie à une agricultrice les
occupants de la voiture qui a foncé sur
le barrage était visé par une otf une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français il a déjà tweeté sur la sur le
CHG il a sauté dessus pour la majorité à
l'inverse il s'agit de calmer évidemment
la colère et très très rapidement parce
que dans quelques semaines commence le
salon de l'agriculture dans les allées
duquels le président de la République a
l'habitude de défiler des heures l'an
dernier Macron avait déjà été un peu
chahuté en cas de poursuite et
d'extension du mouvement agricole sa
visite pourrait être très chaotique et
les images donc très catastrop à
quelques mois des élections européennes
on peut imaginer que ça va inciter
Gabriel hatal à voilà à répondre à
certaines des revendications des des
agriculteurs je vous donne la parole
tout de suite mais pr vouliez réagir à
cet accident tragique dans dans dans
l'Ariège effectivement on a appris
aujourd'hui que les les passagers de de
la voiture qui a forcé le barrage étai
sous le coup sous le coup d'une OCF
écoutez d'abord moi j'ai beaucoup de
compassion pour le monde agricole
évidemment cette famille je trouve
indigne ses réactions voilà je vous le
dis sur lestf c'est pas le sujet du tout
toute récupération de ce style est
totalement indigne moi je voudrais juste
réagir sur sur ce que l'on vient
d'entendre pour dire d'un côté on a
double langage macroniste en disant on
fait une pause environnementale on
regarde on discute on arrive on va faire
un plan et cetera et puis les 23 députés
macronistes de renaissance en tout cas à
l'Europe qui vont voter exactement le
contraire de la pause donc il faut
obligatoirement une cohérence pour
parler aux agriculteurs et puis de
l'autre côté on a un Front national
enfin un rassemblement national qui ne
s'occupe absolument pas d'agriculture au
niveau européen qui a exactement le même
nombre de députés que Renaissance au
niveau européen et qui n'a jamais aidé
les républicains qui travaillent sur
l'agriculture à passer des amendements
et des réformes à ce qui était proposé
notamment par la commission
Environnement et Monsieur cafin du
groupe qu'fin du groupe Renaissance en
Europe donc on a vraiment faut pas
prendre les agriculteurs pour des idiots
alors évidemment le message il est plus
général et il est adressé à tous les
Français mais en ce qui concerne
l'agriculture je trouve que d'un côté il
y a une incohérence entre les propos et
les actes de l'autre côté il y a
vraiment une incompétence parce que dire
qu'on sort totalement des accords de
libre échange sans rentrer dans la comp
complexité de ces accords c'est
complètement de l'amateurisme vouliez
réagir simplement m'associer à ce que
vous avez dit sur l'utilisation
politique de ce de ce drame qui me
paraît tout à fait euh
euh tout à fait pas approprié euh et et
et puis deuxième chose insister
peut-être en fonction de ce que vous
avez dit euh j'ai bien que les médias
adorent la mise en scène de ce match
mais il y a une disyssymétrie très forte
dans la situation de l'un et de l'autre
il y en a un qui est tête de liste qui
peut raconter à peu vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs qui peut raconter à peu près
n'importe quoi parce qu'il fait des
promesses qui de toute façon et puis il
y en a un autre qui est en
responsabilité et je crois qu'il faut
jamais oublier ça parce qu'évidemment ça
ça je veux dire ça ça ça conditionne ce
match et ce match je pense qu'il est il
est pas forcément la chose qu'on peut
souhaiter comp complètement pour les
élections européennes je pense qu'il
faut qu'il y ait un match entre les
têtes de liste des élections européennes
qui ne se résumera pas à au match actuel
mais ti pche on le disait hier puce
qu'on avait déjà un premier débat
consacré à à la colère des agriculteurs
la France est le pays qui reçoit le plus
d'argent l'Union européenne dans le
cadre de la politique agricole commune
c'est pas forcément su c'est pas
forcément beaucoup
médiatisé est-ce que est-ce que l'Europe
pourrait protéger mieux protéger ses
agriculteur parce que c'est ça le cœur
du débat alors c'est pas forcément su
mais c'est pas non plus incohérent étant
donné que la France est la première
puissance agricole deunion euréne je dis
pas que c'est incohérent et vu ce
qu'elle apporte aussi au budget européen
la contrepartie c'est 10 milliards par
an à peu près c'est assez assez logique
au regard notamment de sa production
encore une fois oui mais on est dans un
pays où on aime bien taper sur l'Europe
en tout cas certains responsables
politiques donc voilà ça fait pas de mal
de le rappeler ah ben je je je imagine
assez mal une France sans politique
agricole commune ça a quand même été un
un élément qui a permis de moderniser
notre agriculture d'accéder à
l'autosuffisance et donc de de faire
exercer à l'échelle européenne not une
espèce de souveraineté alimentaire en un
temps record on est devenu quasiment
autouffisant on a beaucoup parlé de
cette souveraineté alimentaire mais
cette souveraineté alimentaire on quand
on regarde bien les éléments chiffrés et
l'étude récente de France agrimaire elle
est pas totalement en péril on a encore
des secteurs particulièrement solide il
y en a où effectivement la situation
économique s'est dégradée le cas de la
volaille par exemple est un
emblématique les fruits et légumes
évidemment ça c'est encore sur une
période beaucoup plus longue et il y a
des menaces quand on apprend qu'en 2023
l'Europe est devenue le le la la
l'Ukraine est devenue le second
fournisseur de sucre derrière le Brésil
de l'Union européenne alors qu'il y a en
France en Allemagne un peu en Belgique
des producteurs de betterave et des
sucreries il y a quelque chose qui
interpelle quand même là il y a il y a
le débat est posé sur la souveraineté
alimentaire parce que le surc est quand
même un poste important pour nous et il
faut pas oublier que le sucre c'est pas
uniquement des usages alimentaires dans
la transition justement écologique il y
a aussi des usages énergétiques des
usages dans l'industrie on peut même
alimenter les les animaux avec la pulpe
de betterrave donc voilà il faut essayer
de de d'avoir aussi une vision un peu
globale de ce qu'on veut faire de cette
agriculture à l'échelle européenne Rémi
Duma il y a l'une des revendications euh
qu'on entend beaucoup euh chez les
agriculteurs je voudrais savooir ce que
vous en pensez c'est c'est aussi le
sentiment qu'il y a parfois un peu deux
poids de mesure c'est au sein même de
l'Union européenne des des des normes
qui s'appliquent pas exactement de la
même façon et euh les agriculteurs
français qui parfois en souffrent mais
exactement on a une politique agricole
commune qui a souvent rien de commun euh
donc il y a des règles européennes mais
bien souvent euh laisser libre choix so
au au gouvernement de chaque pays de
faire ce qu'ils veulent exactement et de
les mettre un petit peu à leur sauce et
c'est vrai qu'en France on a la fâcheuse
tendance de vouloir être premier de la
classe et plus blanc que blanc sur le
papier c'est plutôt sympa en réalité
effectivement ça nous met en concurrence
déloyale à chaque fois parce que nous
avons plus de normes du coup et plus de
restrictions notamment sur les produits
phytosanitaires on est le pays avec le
plus de restrictions et le moins de
molécules active euh autorisé et puis
c'est toutes les questions sociales ça a
été dit aussi tout à l'heure avec le le
coû de la main d'œuvre qui est plus cher
en france avec une inflation alors j'ai
pas envie de rentrer dans les chiffres
mais voilà une agriculture qui coûte
cher à produire au final et du coup qui
nous met en concurrence à l'intérieur
même de l'UR pardon r Je vous interroms
parce que il nous reste 30 secondes la
la la mesure la plus importante que
pourrait annoncer Gabri à la tale là
dans les dans les prochaines heures ou
dans les prochains jours pour vous c'est
quoi vraiment en quelques
mots c'est une pose normative euh déjà
donc d'arrêter de surtransposer les
normes de nous en mettre des nouvelles
euh c'est des leviers fiscaux aussi euh
à mettre en place notamment mais comme
je vous disais sur les transmissions sur
l'installation euh et puis sur les aides
parce qu'aujourd'hui quand on on reçoit
des aides certes mais es sont quand même
taxé derrière euh donc il y a aussi des
incohérences là-dessus et puis c'est
cette vision d'avenir euh qu'est-ce que
l'on veut comme agriculture demain en
France euh et faire cet équilibre entre
souveraineté alimentaire et écologie
parce qu'effectivement ça peut
collaborer mais par contre il faut du
bon sens paysan pour le mettre en place
merci beaucoup remémy Duma merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vais
rappeler Jér Guilbert le titre de votre
livre le grand malentendu euh climatique
ce livre est publié aux Éditions de
l'Aube à bientôt sur Public Sénat